ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich mal sagen
werde aber minecraft ist somit das
realistischste spiel das ich hier
gespielt habe
also das hier ist ja dass minecraft wie
wir es alle kennen über all diese blöcke
alles total verpixelt er sieht irgendwie
alles nicht so übertrieben ist nice aus
allerdings gibt es ja die option in
minecraft shader zu installieren und
haben sie das minecraft das sonst
normalerweise so aussieht plötzlich so
aus und ist viel schöner geworden dass
hier ist der sonic extreme lightning
shader also mit der krasseste shader der
für minecraft herausgebracht wurde wir
sehen dass hier an dem wasser das ist
dass ich das total verändert hat das
gras weht im wind und wir haben gerade
bei der sonne und auch bei licht sachen
ganz andere animationen und effekte das
fällt besonders auf wenn wir einfach
times at night machen und alles so ein
bisschen dunkler wird dann sehen wir
schon hier fordert das licht und so
weiter und so fort das sieht alles viel
viel krasser aus da hinten leuchtet der
mond durch und auch wenn wir mal hier
rein gehen sie mir schon hey das sieht
mégane eis aus aber
und jetzt kommt es in dem mit wichtiges
video machte der extreme lightning
shader ist megaschön dass sie mit dem
mond aussieht oder auch hier mit dem
kloster mit den fackeln mit dem licht
allgemeinen allerdings freunde ich
konnte endlich aufs eis ptg ie6
das ist der grund für das heutige video
in den shader reinhaut sieht alles erst
mal so aus gar nicht mal so schön man
sieht auch nicht so viel dass dieser
shader aber macht ist er verändert die
lichtquellen in minecraft und das seht
ihr besonders wenn ich jetzt hier rein
gehe ich mache mir meine hand und das
inventar weg leute das ist minecraft ich
meine schaut euch einfach mal an da ist
eine spiegelung von dem kloster und hier
oben der und die farbe von dem
lapislazuli block und dem redstone blog
das vermischt sich alles im sonnen lila
ton der hier an den wänden sich
widerspiegelt hier ist auch sein red
storm blog das sieht auch noch mal viel
krasser aus da sehen wir auch noch mal
die reflektion leute das sieht aus finde
ich wie so ein ränder foto erstelltes 3d
modell schaut euch mal die reflektionen
an ich habe noch etwas weiteres
vorbereitet und zwar gehen wir einfach
mal hier so einen kleinen weg lang und
sehen schon hier vorne das hier ist ein
redstone block und das ist ein
lapislazuli blog das hier ist glaube ich
eine seele hat herrn aber dies irgendwie
nicht einleuchten schaut euch das
einfach mal an der macht so blaues licht
hier vorne und der hier vorgemacht rotes
licht und das beides trifft sich in der
mitte dann wird es lila das
minecraft ist dadurch so krass
realistisch geworden das ist ein neuer
shader der wurde von sonic at
herausgebracht einem der kostet 10 euro
ich kann auch ein jahr an der seite noch
eine fackel dran machen dann seht ihr
schon leute ich weiß nicht genau ich
darauf gerade so krass ab weil alter
dieses licht es ist guck mal alte achtet
einfach mal darauf wie sich das licht
jetzt verändert wie schön das einfach
ist jetzt mache ich die fackel da weg
alter ich bin das ist einfach minecraft
poren gerade ich mache jetzt mal den
stecker raus dann seht ihr wie es ohne
diesen shader aussehen würde also
wirklich das hier weg so sieht das ganze
ohne schilder aus und jetzt ich schreibe
ich jetzt genau hierhin und jetzt ist
wieder drin
wie krass verändert der bitte das spiel
und das licht ich glaube jeder der
minecraft mal gespielt hat beziehen weil
sie das spiel eventuell immer noch
spielt weiß was das hier für ein krasser
schritt ist das ist ein shader wie
bereits gesagt er ist nicht kurz schaffe
ich nicht mehr durch die tür raus zu
gehen oder was das ding ist allerdings
und das ist denke ich noch ein bisschen
ausbaufähig ist das natürlich
beschwerden auf einem hohen niveau aber
wenn ich das ganze auf den tag stelle
seht ihr schon sieht immer noch aus alt
der besser aus als es ist normale
minecraft ohne scheint aber es ist
wirklich am helllichten tag
naja sieht es nicht mehr so krass aus
hier drin ist es natürlich eher dunkel
aber ich glaube ich könnte dieses video
auch einfach einen luca verpacktes durch
eine tür zu laufen ich glaube er
versteht mich und wissen was ich meine
wenn ich sage hey tag sieht das ganze so
olsen ist es nicht so schön aber wenn
ich jetzt einfach mal auf nacht setzte
also hinsichtlich licht et cetera
beschweren kann ich mich da
normalerweise eher weniger das ist alles
noch in der alpha also es ist noch nicht
irgendwie getestet worden mega krass ist
noch keine fertige version aber dass die
beispielsweise im blog auf redstone und
jetzt setzt sich einfach mal ein
lapislazuli blog daneben und ihr seht
schon wie hier der boden ich weiß ja mal
das so gut erkennen kann ich kann auch
mal ein bisschen schnee drauf packen ihr
seht schon wie das dann jetzt so lila
wird das was ich meine
hier ist der schnee blau hier ist der
schnee dann rot an der ecke und hier
dazwischen wird der soli la weil die
farben ineinander
das ist keine ahnung habe ich hier
gerade irgendwie total dumm rüberkommen
aber ich finde das mega mega krass für
mich als jemand der in minecraft jahre
verbracht hat gefühlt ist es so krass
dass zu sehen
an der stelle ich das heute wieder
zeitlich aber enden meiner lieben
freunde ich habe vor ein paar tagen in
meinem youtube recommendations das video
gesehen raytracing wie minecraft is more
real denn real life und hab mir dann
einfach gedacht hey ich kaufe er auch
diesen steger und man schaut euch ihr
seht ihr hier
es sieht so unnormal krass aus die
reflektionen das licht wie es sich
spiegel tc3 ich bin kommt komplett
begeistert einfach nur wenn euch das
heutige video gefallen hat würde ich
mich sehr sehr sehr sehr toll aber einen
daumen hoch von euch unter diesem video
hier freuen abonniert main kanal falls
ihr noch kein teil der lupus und
schreibt mir auch bei uns in die
kommentare
ob ich eventuell mit diesem shader mal
wieder mehr minecraft spielen soll falls
ja was euch zocken eine neue welt machen
meine alte welt weiter zurückgehen
welche minigames schränkt sie und die
kommentare morgen um 15 uhr kommen diese
59 produkte in den lukas ob also schaut
dort auf jeden fall morgen mal vorbei
sollten wir da beenden
[Musik]